i don't know if you remember this like a
year ago you were sitting in there
and um you were thinking about you were
talking to a bunch of labels
and i was just telling you like bro
what is this label gonna do for you you
already have a song with their biggest
rapper right right
you already have a song with drake
you are about to be on a national tour
with russ so what can they do for you
besides give you money right
and let's be honest
if you just drop some merch or you just
do what you do not get the money the
money is going gonna come right so the
bag had to be substantial for you to
consider going down that route yeah
definitely the bag was definitely great
and it's like i want to i want to be all
over you know what i'm saying i want to
be able to you already are
that's a fact but you know what i'm
trying to say i'm trying to cover the
[ __ ] mad man listen i understand that
i understand that and i hope that def
jam does that for you i hope they do too
my my suspicions are
you get that bag and you're gonna be
like you know what
i'm doing all this [ __ ] myself anyway
bro you're [ __ ] i'm telling you what
you what you have you i don't even think
you understand it bro like i know you
you know you're worth and i know you
know what you're worth but i'm just like
bro like
they would they should hire you now
that's a fact they should hire you to
help them with their artists and this
and it's not all about the money
sometimes it's like for me this this was
another big incentive for me
is that i need to be in these rooms now
just think this is real [ __ ]
you're in the rooms
no no listen this is real [ __ ] i think i
was which draft was i watching and i saw
your [ __ ] i was like this
[ __ ]
did you see that uh yeah nba draft [ __ ]
right nba [ __ ] roc nation brunch
everything all off uh
my cousin's getting a record deal and
i'm saying it all off of that no also
for your work as a quality yeah what you
do yeah so imagine when
but trust me when you're in this
business you know that it was still a
lot of people who gave beneath that cold
shoulder because i wasn't the one with
the [ __ ] situation
that's a fact but [ __ ] but
now i can get in certain rooms and i
could you know what i'm saying now
certain people got to shake my hand you
know what i'm saying well this is me
benny trust me brother
i got love for you genuine love
and i hope that you're i hope that this
works
but
all the [ __ ] we're talking about like
fam you got a song with drake you just
dropped a song with j cole independently
he did the [ __ ] video right right
[ __ ] the room you are the room that's a
fact
i'm gonna show you i'm gonna show you if
someone hits you that cold shoulder [ __ ]
them i'ma show you what i'm talking
about it's not even though it's not even
like rappers it's like business [ __ ]
it's certain things that i'm trying to
do i got movies coming out i know you're
on your acting [ __ ] we're gonna get to
that exactly you got the sports agency
sports agency like i got so much [ __ ]
that i'm trying to do that these moves
these moves don't even be about the
music a lot of times it'd be about my
next move you know what i'm saying so
hey chad's not checkers that's a fact
and to be honest with you i love
everybody at dev jam you know what i'm
saying good people and snoop's the man
yeah yeah you know what i'm saying and
and it's transparency over there and
it's all that and that's what i that's
what i needed before i did some [ __ ]
like that with a major label because i
could have done this years